bienvenidos a una nueva emisión de
reporteros gracias por estar con
nosotros en septiembre de 2020 estalló
un nuevo conflicto entre dos repúblicas
soviéticas azerbaiyán y armenia el
primero lanzó una guerra relámpago en la
disputada región de nagorno karabaj que
dejó al menos 6.000 muertos esta zona es
reconocida internacionalmente como base
tim pero había estado manejada por
armenios desde 1994 luego de seis
semanas de enfrentamientos hubo un
acuerdo de paz entre a series y armenios
para poner fin al conflicto militar y la
región poblada por armenios sufrió una
aplastante derrota y vio una gran parte
de su territorio diezmado azerbayán se
quedó con zonas del territorio en
disputa y armenia acuerdo retirarse como
afrontan los habitantes este trauma qué
papel juega allí rusia que patrocinó el
alto el fuego firmado el 10 de noviembre
de 2020 y qué papel juega turquía esta
es la historia
[Música]
a una gran parte de nuestros jóvenes
amenas jabalina y bng
[Música]
mis tres hermanos fueron asesinados los
dos se fueron a combatir en jaruco parís
estuve en hierros para sus cadáveres
fueron identificados gracias a pruebas
de adn o ir al diario del ente analizó
aunque tal los rostros de los muertos de
la guerra están presentes en el centro
de este pana kers en la capital del alto
karabaj a nadie ha olvidado el ruido de
los bombardeos ni la humillación de la
derrota ante azerbaiyán
[Música]
esta es mi tercera guerra en el auto
para abajo que quieren que les diga
y no sabemos cómo terminará todo esto
todos estos muertos habrán servido para
algo
tenemos el deber de reconquistar
nuestras tierras en nombre de todos los
que derramaron su sangre
bien sea por medio de la guerra o con
medios pacífico para los armenios del
alto karabaj a declararon su
independencia al final de la era
soviética hasta entonces eran ciudadanos
de azerbaiyán país tuco parlante y de
mayoría musulmana pero armenia impuso
esa decisión a costa de una larga guerra
que terminó en 1994
a finales de septiembre de 2020 un nuevo
conflicto estalla entre las dos antiguas
repúblicas soviéticas potencia petrolera
dirigida por una mano de hierro
azerbaiyán obtiene esta vez una victoria
aplastante contra armenia en tan sólo
seis semanas turquía brinda una ayuda
decisiva con sus drones de última
tecnología y sus mercenarios enviados de
bercy reflejos la guerra deja miles de
muertos en ambos bandos al término de un
alto el fuego apadrinado por moscú la
república autoproclamada de alto karabaj
o arzak pierde una gran parte de
territorio que estaba bajo su control en
particular la zona tampón con armenia
conquistada durante los años 90
el pueblo de karabaj se extiende sobre 7
km
y el kilómetro la mitad está más abajo
ahí donde vivimos nosotros los armenios
y el resto está en manos de los turcos a
los que el alcalde del pueblo llama
turcos son en realidad azerbaiyanos los
habitantes casi nunca hacen la
distinción muchas localidades han tenido
la misma suerte que trabajo divididas en
dos por la guerra y por las nuevas
fronteras impuestas por el alto del
fuego
a 100 metros están nuestras posiciones y
a 150 metros se ve la bandera turca dos
banderas y dos bandos que se enfrentan
separados por una minúscula franja de
tierra
oleg nos lleva a donde una familia cuya
casa estaba en la línea de frente
cuando empezaron las operaciones
militares en la zona los muchachos del
pueblo organizaron nuestra defensa y
combatieron el enemigo nos bombardeo y
unos proyectiles cayeron sobre nuestra
casa desde que empezaron los comba
a partir de ahora llegará el momento en
los campos en los alrededores todavía se
ven las hendiduras dejadas por los tiros
de artillería se necesitarán largas
semanas para poder llevar a cabo una
reconstrucción aquí cayó un proyectil mi
cama ardió en llamas el techo se
derrumbó todo quedó destruido pero más
allá de las destrucciones aliana le
preocupa la proximidad del enemigo
ambos toda la historia de armenia
trabajo nunca había sido conquistada por
los turcos aunque nos habríamos
imaginado que una cosa así fuera posible
los turcos pudieran llegar hasta aquí
los turcos están ahí
y ahí están en todas partes nosotros nos
vamos a quedar porque esta es la casa
que construyó
muchos pueblos de la región cayeron en
manos de azerbaiyán
nos dirigimos hacia la ciudad cercana de
martín
[Aplausos]
donde hubo importantes destrucciones
durante la guerra
con su martini y su región quedaron
particularmente afectadas los trabajos
de reconstrucción avanzan con lentitud
los problemas ligados a las
infraestructuras son importantes en
particular en cuanto al suministro de
electricidad y agua hijos el trabajo no
falta en marzo tal como lo muestra este
cráter en medio de un terreno de fútbol
vestigio de un bombardeo miembro del
gobierno del alto karabaj ahí que kan
humana también participó en el conflicto
encabezando una brigada de 70
no parece creer en una paz duradera
no estaba en esta región siempre hemos
tenido guerras hay una nueva cada 25 o
30 años no creo que sea posible
recuperar territorios a través de medios
pacíficos están tener que recurrir a la
guerra
como ramsés pateras mi versión una
opinión ampliamente compartida por una
población que participó de manera masiva
en el conflicto lo demuestran los
servicios de rescate en primera línea
durante los enfrentamientos este
edificio y otro más alto quedaron
destruidos tras el bombardeo el ataque
de los turcos venía desde allá los
hicimos retroceder ya habían los
vehículos blindados incendiados que les
pertenecían fue ahí donde paramos su
avanzada
los combates se detuvieron en estas
posiciones en la noche del 9 de
noviembre el 9 de noviembre de 2020
fecha del alto el fuego para impedir la
caída de martín para mí sus colegas a
veces cambiaron sus camillas por armas
y nuestra misión principal era ante todo
evacuar a los heridos y traer los
cuerpos pero también participamos en los
combates en la medida de lo posible
para muchos voluntarios civiles venidos
de armenia o miembros de la diáspora
también le prestaron una gran ayuda al
ejército regular aunque esto no modificó
el resultado de la guerra
el jefe de bahram señala como
responsable al gobierno armenio
el pueblo no fue derrotado el ejército
no fue derrotado
más bien se intentó que nosotros
fuéramos derrotados que empiecen por
aclarar lo que pasó en armenia en la
amada de patria cuando vayas a ereván se
lo preguntara esa pasión y las palabras
que se volvieron comunes
cada vez más habitantes acusan al primer
ministro armenio nicole para xinjiang de
haber sido un mal líder militar y de
haber vendido el alto karabaj a en
elevan todos los partidos de oposición
no piden su renuncia
pajín jean terminó por aceptar que se
hicieran elecciones legislativas
anticipadas en junio
la casa de baran quedó completamente
destruida o durante los bombardeos toda
su familia fue reubicada a este
apartamento la esposa de barack trajo al
mundo la última pequeña hace unas
semanas cuatro generaciones han vivido
la guerra juntas cuando estaba
embarazada cuando empezó la guerra
despertamos a los niños muy temprano
y nos refugiamos en unos sótanos
precisamente en este refugio desde ahí
nos transfirieron a un pueblo alejado
con nuestra seguridad
nos quedamos ahí tres días no
distinguíamos el día de la noche ni
nosotros ni los niños dormíamos
temblábamos de miedo magis domecq
y ojalá podamos tener un respiro para
educar directamente a nuestros hijos
para que tengan una oportunidad de
triunfar
sólo queremos eso paz
nos encontramos con haye que cambian que
realiza una inspección en el monasterio
de amarás cerca de martín y las fuerzas
rusas protegen el edificio situado muy
cerca de la nueva línea de demarcación
una presencia indispensable para el
ministro y para el alcalde de la comuna
herido durante los combates
el ejercito azerbayano está ubicado en
el pico de las colinas que sobresalen
durante la guerra bombardearon mucho a
maras
pero los proyectiles cayeron al lado de
las murallas
actualmente esta misión de la paz rusa
es la mejor de las garantías para
nuestra seguridad
pensamos
en el exterior los militares rusos pasan
desapercibidos
pero están muy bien desplegados
alrededor del monasterio
moscú envió cerca de 2.000 soldados a la
región para garantizar el alto el fuego
tomaron sus posiciones para un periodo
de cinco años
los rusos controlan el corredor de la
sin único punto de paso que conecta a
armenia con la capital del alto karabaj
a en el camino es imposible no verlos en
la entrada de shows y que retomó
oficialmente su nombre turco souza
3 kilos 2
esta ciudad situada a tan solo 15
kilómetros de stepán akers era el
objetivo más simbólico del conflicto el
presidente azerbaiyano realizó una
visita cuidadosamente organizada cuando
sus tropas retomaron el control
y le ama el iaph no duda en reescribir
la historia de los armenios del alto
karabaj o como en esta visita a una
iglesia del siglo 12 durante la que
niega la autenticidad de las
inscripciones de grabadas en las piedras
a más de 1300 metros de altura el
monasterio de kansas are se mantuvo
lejos de los combates esta joya de la
arquitectura medieval es un lugar de
peregrinación muy apreciado
fue y seguirá siendo una tierra y un
estado cristiano decenas pasaron a estar
bajo el control de azerbaiyán
pero espero que sea algo temporal
sin embargo este clérigo se niega a
denunciar un conflicto con carácter
religioso para él se trata de un asunto
de política
para mercenarios sirios participaron en
los combates
pero no me parece que sea una guerra de
religión ior que por supuesto estamos
rodeados de países y algunos
desafortunadamente son nuestros enemigos
cisnero para bandera está miguel carner
of a box arte
los miembros de esta familia huyeron de
la región de abruzzo actualmente en
manos de azerbaiyán temen lo peor si la
clase política armenia sigue desgarrando
sí
[Música]
y si las cosas siguen así incluso
podemos perder toda armenia
todo depende de nosotros en nuestro
pequeño país hay demasiadas divisiones
debemos combatir esas divisiones para
ser una sola nación un ejército y un
mismo puño en alto
un slogan que se oye con frecuencia en
la cúpula del estado y que no resistió
las realidades de la guerra el alto
karabaj generó un gran orgullo cuando
hizo la secesión hace 30 años este
pequeño pedazo de armenia que no tiene
ningún reconocimiento internacional
actualmente lucha por sobrevivir
[Música]
[Risas]
gracias por acompañarnos en esta emisión
de reporteros una vez más les recordamos
que puede ingresar a nuestra página web
trans 24 puntocom para ver esta emisión
y las anteriores hasta la próxima acción